today's video is sponsored by skillshare
so warm thank you to the whole
skillshare team to supporting the work
on my channel from learning
so you want to know what the up or out
principle in consulting is and how it
really works so for sure when i was a
young student about 10 years ago
this was always a thing that really gave
me headaches when i was thinking about
maybe join consulting after graduation
what does upper out really mean how does
it work
does this mean that i might lose my job
if i do some mistakes on a project will
it just be kicked out of the firm if i'm
not good enough so for sure these were
questions which were in my head and i
didn't really had any resources at the
time to really understand this i always
felt like this is a topic that isn't
really talked about and for sure it's
some recruiting events when i talk to
representatives of any of these firms i
never really felt like that i got a
straight answer that somebody was really
spilling the tea on what our pour out
really means and how it works so in this
video i'm going to do exactly that i'm
going to talk about this little secret
of the consulting works so welcome to
another coffee break here on my channel
from learning my name is heinrich i'm a
former mckinsey consultant and on my
channel i want to help you to become
successful in the first years of your
career so before we start i just want to
be clear that i'm not not
talking about the situation of any
specific firm but rather talking about
the general situation of tier 1
consulting firms and i trust similar
things will be true for tier 2 and tier
3 firms this way it is also important to
understand that within the same firm
how strict this upper old principle is
applied
might vary by geography also because of
course the labor laws a different
country by
country with of course the resulting
implications that come from that so in
this video i will tackle the uproar
principle in three steps
first i'm going to talk about what the
upper hour principle actually
is what does this really mean then
second i'm going to talk about how it
really works in practice and then third
i'm going to talk about what happens
if you are on the out part right so if
the firm asks you decides that you
cannot
work for the firm anymore in the future
so without further ado let's start
what does up or out even mean what is
this even supposed to mean and indeed
another word that some people use
is grow or go and what this really boils
down to is that in the end
throughout your career in consulting you
get either designated either you get
promoted to the next level
every other year or so or at some point
if you are
not getting promoted you will be asked
to leave
the firm so pretty much your work
contract will be terminated you can
assume that this principle is applied in
a rather strict way for all the mbb
firms and other t1 firms and again to
some extent also to tier 2
and three firms but why do consulting
firms do this what is
their rationale for doing that where
they want to keep the pyramid in the
organization and they want to make sure
that they create a system
where the very best get to the top and
the people who maybe do not perform to
these highest levels that they expect
would at some point leave the
organization this is exactly what the
upper all principle is supposed to do
so over time either you're good enough
for the next designation you're
considered worthy to be promoted to the
next level or this is not the case you
are not considered good enough and then
you will need to leave at some point but
of course there is also criticism for
this principle
and maybe you're familiar with the
expression of the peter principle which
pretty much means that in many
organizations people get always promoted
up to the level of their personal
incompetence so people might be very
good highly effective
in the jobs that they used to do but
then they always get promoted
up to a point that they failed they
cannot do this new role anymore and then
often this means that you need to leave
the company as the employee so if you
translate this to consulting what this
means is that
maybe you're a great project lead maybe
you do an excellent
job at managing projects managing your
clients managing your team
but maybe you just do not want to
advance into the junior partner position
as a next step
maybe because you don't want the
lifestyle you don't enjoy the tasks that
you will likely need to do so you would
be very happy just to stay
in your project lead role forever this
is just what you're comfortable with
this is what you enjoy
doing and this is also where you're
really good at and choices like this
are usually not possible in these large
strategy consulting firms where the up
or out principle applies so over time
you
either need to go up or you need to go
out this is really what this boils down
to so let's now move to the second part
how does this really work how is this
principle really applied in practice but
before we jump into it i want to
introduce you to the sponsor of today's
video and this sponsor is
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes for creative and curious people
you can explore new skills
deepen your passions and get lost in
creativity there are classes on
marketing personal
branding presentation skills and many
more all of these are topics that are
highly applicable to a career in
consulting banking or corporate and the
best thing is that i made a slight
writing class for skillshare so you can
access and enjoy it as a skillshare
member
personally i recently took the class
productivity master class
principles and tools to boost your
productivity from the fellow youtuber
ali abdal
it's a great class it taught me many new
aspects of productivity and i very much
enjoyed how you applied the pareto
principle or the 80 20 rule to
productivity
classes on skillshare are specifically
curated for learning there are no
ads they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused and
follow wherever your creativity takes
you and the best thing is that it's less
than ten dollars a month with an annual
subscription skillshare created a
special offer for subscribers of this
channel from learning and so the first
thousand subscribers of me
click on the skillshare link in the
video description we get a free trial of
the skillshare premium membership i hope
this helps you to explore your
creativity
check it out link in the video
description and indeed what most of
these consulting firms have
is that they have very highly
standardized career tracks so if you
join these firms you already know from
day one that in one year you will be
promoted to this level then in another
year on average you will promote to the
next level then in two years to this
level and so on that you have an average
time span until you pretty much know
that this is your
career track that you can follow to get
partner at some point but of course for
each of these steps there is some level
of flexibility and
often this is described as a window so
you have often a certain time window
within you can make the designation to
the next step
what this the means is that in this time
window usually there are three points in
time where you can make the designation
so if you are considered a high
performer if you are considered a rock
star then you might have the chance of
being promoted early in this window so
earlier than your peers and indeed often
this difference is only a couple of
months but if you are really one of
these high performers who always
consistently is able to get promoted
early
this really can add up and then in the
long term you might be able to make
partner one or two or three years
earlier then there's the standard
regular point in time where most people
say 80 percent of all the people will
get designated so this is kind of the
average career track that you will be on
and then there is also this
late promotion the late designation and
this is for the people where for
whatever reason there were not yet
seem fit to be designated in the
standard regular point in time maybe
they got some subpar performance
evaluations maybe there were
some things in their development where
some partners expressed the opinion
they still need to develop a certain
area a certain aspect of their skill set
in order to be ready to take on that new
road
take on this new responsibility that
comes with the promotion attached to it
and then indeed if you are
designated in this late spot then you're
fine
then you're designated and then your
journey continues and then maybe they
have another year or two
until the next window opens and this
gives them plenty of opportunity to
recalibrate also your performance
ratings but then of course what can
happen
is that then within this window there
are people that then do not get
designated and while on the more junior
levels the big majority of people gets
designated
as only a minority who doesn't make this
cut then the most senior you get
up to the partner level of course at
some point the larger the share of the
people who does not make it
will need to leave the firm at some
point in time of course what you need to
understand here is that
these things do not come by surprise you
will have received several instances of
performance reviews before you will not
be surprised that this is then the
result
if it really gets that far if this
really happens to you in the very end
and in a moment we're also going to talk
about what really happens if you are
asked to leave the firm what this
process really looks like so stick with
me here for a moment but again it does
not come as a surprise it is a very
transparent process
and of course the consulting firm that
you work for usually wants you to
succeed they already invested lots of
time and money just to hire you and
already invest a lot of time into your
training so they want you to succeed
so often they're different processes
starting if somebody is starting to fall
behind but you will get coaching where
you will get additional support and then
this does enable lots of people to
indeed improve their performance and
then make the car to not in the end be
in this position where it just doesn't
work out anymore but then of course
every year people
are affected by per hour people need to
leave
then the question is how does this work
what does this really mean and this is
not the third part of this video
so what happens if you need to go and
here the question that i get most often
if i discuss this topic with other
people is that they say
well but they cannot just fire you their
labor laws
there right and of course this is a
sensitive topic for the consulting firm
so everybody has a big interest of not
letting this escalate to some legal type
of situation so what usually happens is
that the consulting firm will approach
you
will just try to work something out with
you so that you can leave on good terms
and all of this
is settled in an amicable way so what
this usually means is that you will get
several months of time not to reorient
yourself for this time you might also
get a paid leave so that you still
receive the salary but can again maybe
do some interviews with other firms with
other companies i'm aware of several
instances where then partners that work
with these affected candidates
tapped into their very own network
trying to find some job opportunities
which would be a good fit with this
person and then trying to help them to
get into this new role after the
consulting time and then
often of course some type of severance
agreement might be part of the deal as
well depending on the individual
circumstances so while there are some
instances where some type of legal
escalation might happen in the end these
are only the rarest cases from my
experience
nobody wins by doing that especially for
the tier 1 firms you can trust that the
consulting firm will do their very best
to find an amicable solution to the
situation that both sides both parties
can live with and of course the other
aspect of that is that because
you as the affected person is the
affected consultant because you
know already far in advance that you are
currently on a slippery slope that maybe
half a year or a year down the line
your future in the firm is really
unclear most people
understand that this is the track that
they are on they already by themselves
try to look around are looking for other
opportunities so many people will
already by themselves have left
the firm before it even gets to this
formal point where the hr professionals
or the responsible partner from the firm
approaches you
to formally let you know that this is
now the process that you're on and you
will need to leave
so but this creates some clarity and
transparency into this topic and that
now you're able to understand the apple
principle much better how it works how
it doesn't work what this really is all
about so as always if you now still have
any questions leave me a comment below
in the comment section and i'll do my
very best to answer all your questions
and of course every comment also helps
me with the youtube algorithm and if you
have your very own
first-hand experiences of the upper-out
principle
maybe you were even affected by it in a
negative way if you want to share your
story i trust this
would be highly valuable for the other
people here in the firm learning
community as well so i highly encourage
you to do that that would be great for
all of us here so now as
always if you took any value out of this
video at all please destroy the like
button for the youtube algorithm and
also subscribe to my channel to stay up
to date on all my content and if you
want to see even more from me i also
have an instagram you can follow me on
my handle from learning and also have a
mailing list there's a signup link to
this mailing list
below in the video description in
addition i'd also love to connect with
you and get in touch on linkedin you can
find the link to my linkedin in the
video description as well so feel free
to just hit me up
reach out to me laughter hearing from
you guys and of course thank you again
to skillshare the sponsor of this video
if you are interested to try out
skillshare yourself have a look at the
skillshare link in the video description
i trust that there are some highly
valuable and insightful classes that you
can take and i want to say thank you to
all the members of from learning you
really are the ogs you are the guys are
really supporting the work here of the
channel and if you want to become a
member of firm learning as well
hit the join button next to the
subscribe button there you will get all
the informations what becoming a member
is all about so if you watched until the
end thank you so much this is warmly
appreciated
my name is heinrich and hyun from
learning i'm releasing videos every
single week on saturday so stay tuned
for next week and until then bye bye
good weekend to all of you cheers guys